(sirène de police)
- Est-ce qu'on a une alerte
pour votre appel?
- Vendredi soir, 20 h,
Benjamin Dansereau-Leclerc,
reçoit un appel de sa centrale
de répartition. On signale
au superviseur aux opé
qu'une policière du SPVM est
suspendue par une jambe,
parce qu'elle s'est retrouvée
prisonnière d'un mécanisme
automatisé d'une porte
de garage.
Gyrophares et sirène
en actions, chaque seconde
compte dans la circulationnsnsn.
BENJAMIN DANSEREAU-LECLERC
superviseur, Urgences-santé
- Là, on a demandé l'équipe
de soins avancés.
Ils peuvent donner des
médicaments pour contrôler
la douleur, le temps qu'on
puisse la désincarcérer,
ce que j'en comprends.
- L'intervention d'urgence se
déroule en hauteur avec l'aide
des pompiers qui utiliseront
les pinces de désincarcération
pour libérer la policière.
Le grave accident est survenu
au moment où elle venait prêter
main-forte à dgugugugugugues sur
le point d'arrêter ce suspect
considéré armé et dangereux.
Après 60 minutes d'intervention
minutieuse, l'agente sera
transportée à l'hôpital pour
soigner une grave fracture
ouverte à la cheville.
- C'est une pa r r r r r r reçu
des doses de fentanyl pour
essayer de contrôler sa douleur
pendant l'intervention,
considérant qu'elle a été
un lon
- Être ambulancier-paramédic
chez Urgence-Santé, c'est
desservir 2,5 millions
d'habitants à Montréal
et à Laval. Les
1100 paramédics traitent
à chaque semaine près
de la moitié de tous les appels
d'urgences au Québec.
- On a aus
de problèmes psycho-socials
reliés à ça, beaucoup
d'itinérance aussi, des
problèmes de consommation,
il y en a partout,
mais c'est certain
que c'est plus concentré ici.
(sirène de police)
- Sitôt dit, Benjamin active
gyrophares et sirène pour
se diriger vers un autre secteur
de Montréal. La soirée e
un feu roulant d'urgence.
Cette fois, c'est un homme
de 80 ans qui s'est faitr r r rà
un coin de rue de son domicile.
Sans délai, il va au secours
de l'homme blessé qui montre
des signes d'hypothermieusususu,
il doit aussi rassurer l'épouse
de l'homme, qui est accouru
sur place.
- Ça va dépendre de son état
en fait. Fait que c'est pas
certain à quel hôpital on va
aller. C'est sûr que c'est une
seule personne dans l'ambulance.
Donnez-moi une petite seconde.
- Si le réseau de la santé fait
face à une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre, les paramédics-
ambulanciers n'échappent pas
à cette réalité. Départs
volontaires ou vague
de retraites, les rangs
se dégarnissent à vitesse
grand "V".
- Je suis là depuis une
trentaine d'années.
- Et Urgence-Santé ne s'en cache
pas, les efforts de recrutement
constants peinent à répondre
à la demande.
JEAN-PIERRE ROULEAU
Urgences-santé
- Cette année, on avait
un objectif d'embaucher
une centaine de paramédics.
On a été en mesure d'en
embaucher une quarantaine.
Donc, il y a un manque à gagner
d'une soixantaine de paramédics.
- Il est arrivé par moment
cette année qu'Urgences-Santé
se retrouve avec un nombre
d'ambulances atteignant
à peine 45 % de son nombre
habituel, qui est d'environ
50 véhicules.
- Pour les gens qui veulent
s'impliquer dans le pré
hospitalier, qui veulent porter
secours, qui veulent venir en
aide. Des gens de coeur, des
gens qui ont envie
de faire la différence dans
la vie de quelqu'un, donc,
je les invite à joindre
les rangs de la profession
de paramédic.
- Le manque de paramédic
représente donc, un enjeu
de santé publique de taille.
On souhaite éviter des
conséquences qui pourraient être
dramatiques si on ne règle pas
le problème dans les prochaines
années.
Ici Pascal Robidas,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.